I worry genuinely about the consequences
of a doctor who has a large following
telling his audience to use something
that he knows is not safe and carry
serious risk hey guys welcome to another
episode of the Wednesday checkup I've
been finding myself spending a lot of
time on Twitter lately trying to get the
most up-to-date information about
coronavirus out there as well as
learning at the same time and I've come
across a few doctors that I found
themselves in hot water after making
some statements about copa90
before we start I want to give a huge
thank you once again to the healthcare
frontline workers doctors pharmacists
nurses everyone that's helping battle
koban 19 seriously from the bottom of my
heart thank you let's start off with dr.
drew who seems to be in the most hot
water right now mostly about his
statements that he made prior to the
corona virus becoming a pandemic way
less virulent that the flu that should
be the headline
way less serious that influenza should
the Olympics be canceled that's funny de
Blasio told them not to ride the trains
they're not riding the trains and and so
I am I mean it's ridiculous the flu
virus in this country is vastly more
consequential it is a press induced
panic Twitter absolutely exploded once
this video went live it got millions of
you seemingly in minutes and look I'm
not gonna lie I got emotional watching
this I got riled up I tell people to not
get anxious because once they get
emotional they make bad decisions and
here I was getting upset the reason why
I got emotional and watching that is
because I started thinking about the
potential consequences they could come
about when a trusted figure like dr.
drew tells people to not worry about
this novel coronavirus
did they go out were they exposed to
this virus did they get potentially
really sick and even lose their lives
where I think dr. drew took his biggest
misstep was not the fact that he was
wrong about the novel coronavirus we're
all entitled to be wrong as experts as
doctors because medicine is an imperfect
science I've said in other videos how
medicine is as much art as it is science
because two doctors can look at the same
situation and have different
interpretations of it I think where he
went wrong was he forgot somewhat that
medicine carries within itself a level
of humility we have to approach it with
a level of humility to me if dr. drew
came out and said something like
look I think in my own expert opinion
that this novel coronavirus won't be as
bad as the media is making it seem but
we'll keep looking at the information I
think that would have been a reasonable
statement to make even though he was
wrong at the end all of this really
serves as a stark reminder that expert
opinion is and should always be
considered the lowest form of evidence
when we talk about levels of evidence we
look at expert opinion basically when a
doctor thinks is right then we move up
to a case series observational studies
then the gold standard randomized
controlled studies then you even have
one up on that where you have a meta
analyses which is many randomized
controlled studies I am pleased to
report though that dr. Jew did issue
this apology my early comments about
equating coronavirus with influenza were
wrong they were incorrect that was part
of a chorus that was saying that and we
were wrong and I want to apologize for
that
interestingly the verb that we use for
medicine is practicing we practice
medicine because we're all bound to make
a mistake especially with how imperfect
our knowledge is for continuously
evolving it and doing better and trying
harder all in all I hope to see dr. drew
bounce back from this incident I know
millions of people look to dr. drew for
medical advice and he brings a really
unique vantage point to medical media
being that he's dually board-certified
in addiction and internal medicine with
a huge focus on mental health I've heard
that dr. Drew's media team has been
issuing copyright takedown notices for
people using the clips that I just used
I really hope they don't come after us
as this is a good learning opportunity
next up we have another popular medical
media figure dr. oz you received some
serious backlash on Twitter for comments
he made on Fox News take a look the
panic attack is devastating and it is a
physical problem it's not just in your
head you're a whole body they have the
rapid palpitations the sweating that
they're feeling think the world is
closing in around you and these symptoms
can cause all kinds of detrimental
effect which is why I think a lot of
doctors now are feeling that the worry
in the panic about coronavirus is gonna
be worse than the actual coronavirus for
them the majority of criticism from
Twitter came from the fact that they
felt dr. oz was misrepresenting the
views of doctors on the
lines who are legitimately more
concerned about coronavirus than they
anxiety that can potentially come from
it I actually happen to agree with
Twitter on this one I have a lot of
doctor friends who are on the front
lines a great example would be dr.
Donald Pettit who was actually in my
hundred doctors video he's an ER
resident
who happens to be working in the ICU
right now he tells me about the
equipment shortages the ICU and
ventilator use that's gone up
tremendously over the last few weeks and
it's scary to him I mean he's on the
front lines potentially getting himself
sick bringing the virus home to his
family he has a newborn baby at home so
I actually went ahead and texted dr. oz
I mentioned the negative criticism he
was getting my thoughts on the subject
and I'm happy to report he was quite
welcoming of that and he said that in
the following interviews he was gonna
make a change in the way he spoke about
this and correct his previous statements
I do live television quite often and I
know how easy it is to have one thing in
your mind and then speak something that
comes out somewhat different so I was
appreciative the fact that dr. oz was
open to this type of feedback and was
willing to change his statements in the
future I think that's how we as doctors
really have to function in order to be
more effective communicators and better
at relaying crucial medical information
to the general public
up next we have quite the polarizing
figure in dr. Joseph Mercola
dr. Joseph Mercola is a practicing
physician he takes a naturopathic
approach to how he treats his patients
he's quite popular online he's actually
found himself in hot water quite a few
times with the FDA for making
unsubstantiated claims about products
that he sells on his website and I
haven't really found any claims that I
was interested in debunking until I saw
a few recent tweets that caught my
attention the first tweet read us such
while unproven one current theory is
that electromagnetic field radiation and
the addition of 5g in particular could
be having an impact on the Cova 19:00
pandemic this is actually a very common
conspiracy theory that's being put out
there on social media forums on reddit
what-have-you here's the problem no
evidence exists to support this theory
let me talk about briefly how we create
theories in science and then how we go
about testing them first and foremost
you have
to have an idea with a plausible
mechanism of how that idea comes to be
for example if you wanted to create
antibiotics before there are antibiotics
you have to think to yourself well this
antibiotic can work in this method to
kill this bacteria thereby eliminating
it from the system you go ahead you
tried it lab models animal models human
models and you work your way out here
there is no plausible mechanism for how
EMF waves or 5g makes people have worse
cases of the novel coronavirus that's
why I wish this tweet ended when he said
while unproven because while it's
unproven we can make any random
correlative statement the fact that
February had an extra day this year
could be a reason why Cova 19 is
affecting us so seriously
you can literally substitute that with
anything and that goes to speak to the
power of the difference between
correlation and causation
remember correlation two things
happening simultaneously 5g and
coronavirus causation is when something
directly causes that thing to happen the
next tweet which i think is the more
problematic of the two reads of such
nebulous hydrogen peroxide therapy is an
inexpensive and simple way to treat most
viral respiratory illnesses all you need
is a nebulizer with a face mask that
covers your mouth and nose and common
household hydrogen peroxide available at
most grocery stores and pharmacies now
there's a few things to unpack here
first and foremost the cdc and fda
clearly state that there exists no
proven methods to treat or prevent kovat
19 and to me when a doctor believes
their own expert opinion outweighs those
of major medical organizations like the
cdc and fda
without substantial evidence you're
crossing a line next let's talk about
the dangers of inhaled hydrogen peroxide
straight from the cdc website hydrogen
peroxide is not absorbed by the skin
but can cause systemic toxicity when
inhaled or ingested I have to read this
next whole segment cause of how serious
is vapours missed or aerosols of
hydrogen peroxide can cause upper airway
irritation inflammation of the nose
hoarseness shortness of breath and a
sensation of burning or tightness in the
chest exposure to high concentrations
can result in severe mucosal congestion
of the trachea and
and delayed accumulation of fluid in the
lungs children may be more vulnerable to
corrosive agents than adults because of
the relatively smaller diameter of their
Airways dr. Mercola
in his own YouTube video actually states
that you should not use common household
hydrogen peroxide the companies put in
stabilizers there and there they're uh
pretty much all proprietary so they
don't have to disclose what those
specific stabilizers are but believe me
they are not intended for human use or
consumption and they are not cleared for
safety studies for human consumption so
these are not designed to be typically
swallowed ingested or inhaled so I worry
genuinely about the consequences of a
doctor who has a large following telling
his audience to use something that he
knows is not safe and carries serious
risk do not nebulize hydrogen peroxide
do not think it's gonna eliminate
covered 19 it's not proven it's not
smart and it's potentially very
dangerous I actually reached out to a
board-certified pediatric ICU physician
dr. David Epstein you may have seen him
on my hundred doctors video and he said
quote unquote so shameful to take
advantage of people like this and
potentially cause harm I've never heard
of anyone doing this and can't help to
think that someone won't walk away with
some kind of pneumonitis I just hope
they don't listen to this advice totally
unethical i 100% agree
I really hope dr. Mercola issues a
retraction and tells his audience which
is a rather large audience the danger of
doing this with hydrogen peroxide please
click here for my hundred doctor's video
I literally interviewed a hundred
doctors in seven days yes this entire
video was made in seven days
these doctors took out the time to get
you the information click on it click on
it click on it while staying happy and
healthy of course
you
[Music]